Aren't you ready? Rock Paper Scissors shoot,
Dylan. I probably did. I probably did. In this
video, we are going to build this amazing Rock
Paper Scissors game. Okay, so it's probably
the sexiest Rock, paper scissors game you've
ever seen in your entire life. Right? Okay,
so without further ado, let's get started. Okay,
so let's, first thing I'm going to do is go to my
desktop and create a folder called Rock, paper,
scissors. Okay. Okay, and let's go inside that.
And we'll do touch index dot HTML styles dot
CSS, and app dot j s. Okay. And then we'll open
this guy and Adam. All right, so it's opened. It's
taken a while these days. I don't know why. Okay,
cool. So let's close these guys down first,
and then let's open up index dot HTML, CSS,
okay. All right. So let's start coding. So the
first thing we have is, first thing we have is
the header. Right? So before that, let's get
the skeleton out of the way. Rock. Paper,
let's call it Rock, paper, scissors,
game or something. Okay. All right,
and let's open this guy up. And let's type in some
gibberish here. Okay. And open browser. Okay, so
this is this is the working version. And this is
the non working version. Okay, so as you can see,
our HTML file is working. So let's get rid of
that. Okay. So the first thing we have is the
header. So let's get that in a header tag, not a
div tag. So far, we've done pretty much everything
in a div tag, and that's okay. But we want to be
more semantic. Okay, so there's a header. It's
a header, so we want to put it in the header tag.
If it's a footer, we want to put it in footer tag,
okay. And then later on, we'll go over section
two, but in this video, we'll just for those,
we'll just do depth. Okay, so header, and then
this one has an h1 Rock, paper, scissors. Okay.
Okay, let's go here. Refresh. Okay. That's how
it looks hideous. Right. So we'll add the CSS
later. Okay, so that's the header. And then
we have a div for choices. No, no, no, we have
the scoreboard, diff. So we'll give it a class
of scoreboard. Okay. And then in our scoreboard,
we have two badges, right user and computer,
it's on the edges. But we'll do that with CSS
later. But we have two badges, user and computer
and then we have the scores themselves. Zero is
your starting numbers stewards are okay. So for
that we'll do div of let's do, let's see, this
one is going to be user. So we'll say user. And
for this, we'll give it a badge, class of badge,
we'll copy this paste, and the next one is going
to be computer comp, okay? Now, classes are cool,
because we can share, you know, the same cells
across those two divs, right with the same class
called badge. But we also want some IDs because we
want to uniquely position the user and comp later,
right? Because the users on the left hand, and
then kompass on the right hand side. So what we
want to do is say ID of let's say we give it a
ID of user label. And then for this one, we'll
give it an ID of comp, computer label. Okay? All
right. So once we have this, let's go back and see
how it looks. All right. Nothing special. Okay,
so let's go and now actually put the scores. Okay,
so now what we do is add a span tag, not a div
tag, because they're in the same line spans are in
line element. divs are block level elements. Okay?
So, span will do zero, right? It starts from zero.
Later, we'll change it. But for now, we'll start
with zero. And we want to give the first span an
ID of user score, because the left hand side is
going to be user right? And then we want to copy
this and then paste it. Okay. So copy, paste, and
we want a colon in the middle, and then we'll call
this computer score. Okay, so now refresh. Okay,
that's how it looks so far. Okay. All right. Let's
keep moving. Now, we also need the message, right?
So now we need the paper covers rock message. So
for that, we'll create a div here, and we'll give
it a class of I don't know result, okay? And then
we'll say paragraph and we'll say paper. Well,
paper covers. I can't type anymore. Rock you went,
Okay, cool. And now let's go back, refresh that.
That's how it looks. Okay. Now, we want to add
the choices, right, these images. Okay, so for
that we'll do div of class of choices. And then
we'll have inner divs. Okay, well, we'll have
those images wrapped inside each depth, okay,
so we'll do div. And we'll say choice because
it's a bunch of choices. So we'll have a choice
for each one of them. And then we'll do image and
right Now I don't have images in my directory. As
you can see, I don't have images, right. So what
I'll do is I'll pull it from my working directory,
okay. So from this folder and put it in this
folder, copy it, basically. So what I'll do is
open hyper. Okay, and let's do this. Cool. So now
I have the images here. If you see here, there it
is, right? These are all images. Don't worry about
the DS store. That's nothing. So I just copied it
and paste it in here. Okay. So now what I can do
is go here, image source and I can say images,
slash. It's called rock. I think rock, PNG. The
first one is rock, right? Okay. And then I'll copy
this three times. One time, two time, okay. And
then this one is going to be okay. Let me first
refresh it. Okay. That's how it looks so far.
And now I'll change this to paper. Refresh. Okay,
that that's how it looks. And then for the third
one, we'll do scissors. Cool. So now we have the
images. And I think that's it for them. Oh, we
also want to add some IDs to each of these dips,
okay, because later on, we want to be able to
identify each Rock paper scissors, okay. So what
we do is, we just give it an ID of our, okay,
we don't need to say rock, and then Id of P,
and then Id of S. Alright, so that's it for the
choices. So we'll let's go down. Hold on. Okay,
cool. All right. Now, what do we have left? We
have this message left, right, make your move.
So let's do that. Okay, so let's P, and all you
do is let's give it an ID of action message. Okay,
action message. Sounds weird. And then all you
do is make your move. Okay? Alright, so now let's
go here, refresh. That's how it looks like. Okay,
cool. So now let's actually add the styles. Before
I add any styles, I want to make sure I link it.
So link, and we'll go here and say, styles dot
CSS, okay. And now when I write something in
here, let's do body background to like red or
something. Okay? Boom. Okay, so it works. Okay, so
let's get rid of it. Again. As always, let's start
off with the universal selector. Get rid of the
default margin and padding. So before I do that,
let's refresh here. Oh, let's get rid of it. Okay,
refresh. What? Okay, margin zero padding zero. And
then we want box sizing to border box. Okay. And
refresh that right? margins are gone. Okay. So the
first thing we have to do is we have to style this
header. So for that, we will say, so let's go to
index we have header, and we'll just say, header.
Okay, header background to be white, right? It's
white. And what is it? And for the text color,
we'll do header h1, header, h1. Color is? What
does that color. Let's get that color. Hold on
just a second. Let me open up my color picking
tool. Alright. And the color is. Let's see.
Alright, that's the color. Okay. So let's go here,
refresh. Okay, that's how it looks like right
now. Nothing special. And we also want to text
align this to center, and then font family to ASAP
and then backup is sensor. Okay, so let's see if
that works. Alright, so that looks good. And now
we also want some margins and padding. So we'll do
margin or padding of 20 pixels on the parent.
So there should be some breathing room. Okay,
cool. And now, as you can see here, this,
the entire body's background is this dark,
bluish color, right. So for that, we'll just go
right above this, and we'll say body background
color to that color. So again, let's grab that
color. Boom, boom, okay. Okay, and actually,
this should be a color for this one, too. Okay,
cool. Refresh. And there it is. Right. So now
it's looking a lot similar. Okay, cool. And now we
also want to let's see, what do we want to do? Oh,
sorry about that. We have not imported the ASAP.
Font yet, right. So you guys probably know how to
do it. Go to fonts.google.com fonts.google.com
Then go to ASAP. Right, go to ASAP. Click this
plus button, and then go come down here, click
on this go to Customize, you want to get the,
you know, bold and medium. You don't need to
but you know, it's better if you have options,
right? So grab that. Go here to CSS go up at the
top, paste it and boom, right? It's done. Now,
if we go back here, right, right now it looks like
this. I'm gonna refresh and there it is. Right?
It's a little different. Okay? Once we have this
now we have to style the scoreboard, right? Okay,
so what I'll do is let's go to scoreboard, okay,
because we gave it a class of scoreboard right?
If you guys remember, we gave this div a class of
scoreboard. So we'll do a scoreboard I'll first
give it a border of three pixels solid white.
Okay, let's see how it looks. Okay, that's how
it looks right now. It's 100% width, okay? We
don't want it to be 100% width, we want it to
be less than that. So 200 pixels or something.
Okay, refresh. Okay, that looks a lot better. But
now this one's too close to the header, right?
So we want some space at the top and bottom.
So for that, we'll give it a margin. Whoa, margin
of, let's say 20 pixels at the top and bottom and
then center it. Okay. So we'll do enter. And there
it is, right? It's centered. And then we have 20
pixels at the top and 20 pixels at the bottom.
Okay, so that looks good. Now, we also want to
change the text, write the font color, okay, so
the font color is going to be white. Fresh, Okay,
that looks good. And we also want to change the
font size to be 40 pixels and 46 pixels, I think.
There. That's right. So that looks gigantic
right now, but we'll fix it in a bit. Okay,
this user and comp is supposed to be out of
the box. So for that, before I go into that,
let's also fix the border radius. Because if you
guys notice here, this one's kind of rounded. This
one's not rounded. So border radius is going to
be let's do four pixels. Refresh. Okay. That's how
it looks like. Cool. We'll also text align that
all this to center. Okay, refresh. Alright, that
looks good. And we'll also give it some padding of
let's do 15 pixels and the top and bottom and 20
pixels to the left and right. Okay, so there's
some breathing room now. And we also want to
change the font family. Okay. And let's do ASAP.
And then sensor. Okay, cool. Refresh. Alright,
so that looks good. But now we also want to style
these guys. Okay, these bad boys. So for that,
we'll go down here. And if you guys remember, we
called them badges, right? We gave him a class of
badges. So we'll first style that and then we'll
go into user label and computer label. Okay,
so we'll go Hold on. Okay. And we'll say dad,
badge. background is going to be let's get that
background color. Okay. Boom. Come on. Why is it
not working? Okay. The color is bad guy. Okay.
So background is that and we also want to color
to be white. It's, I think it's already white,
but just make sure. Okay, that's how it looks
like. Cool. Once we have that, now, let's change
the font size because that's humongous. So we'll
do font size to be 14 pixels, okay? And then we'll
give it a padding of two pixels on the top and
bottom and then give some padding on the right and
left. And we'll also give it a font family of ASAP
sensor. Okay, fresh. Okay, that's how it looks
like. Right? Okay, so the styling is good. But now
we need to take it, we need to position the user
to the left hand column to the right, right. So
what we do is for that, if you guys remember we
gave these IDs of user label and computer label so
we'll do user label, okay. And we'll do position
of absolute again, if you guys don't know what
positioning is just go watch my like CSS videos,
okay, and then my previous project videos, so. So
if I do top zero, left zero, it will position it
to the browser's top left corner, there are less
right, but that's not what we want. We want the
starting position to be not the browser's top left
corner but the parent this scoreboards top left
corner, okay, so that it's easier to do things
and it's more consistent later when we resize our
screen. Okay, so for that, we will have to give
our scoreboard which is our parent right here,
the parent of this, there's the scoreboard so
we'll give this a position. Have something other
than static or inherit, okay? So which is we'll
just say relative. Alright, now refresh, and
it starts from the scoreboards top left corner,
right? So once we have this now we can position
it. So we'll say top of 30 pixels. And then we'll
say left of if you do positive, we'll push it,
push it to the right, we don't want to push it to
the right, we want to push it to the left, right.
So refresh, that's how it looks like. And if I do
negative, it looks like this. Right? So we want
negative 25. Let's see. Okay, that looks good.
And now we'll copy this and do the same thing
for your computer, right? So computer and position
absolute top 30 pixels. And then now we don't want
to do left here. We can we can do left. Okay, so
if I refresh, that's how it looks like right now.
Right? It's hiding behind the users hiding behind
the computer. So if I do here instead of negative
25, if I do like 35 pixels, right, right, now
it's right there. But let's just do right. Okay,
instead of left, we'll just do a right. So and
then now it starts from the right hand side. So
if I do zero pixels here, it starts from the right
hand side, you see that, right? But we don't want
to do zero pixels. And if we give it a positive
number, it will push it to the left. If I do 10
pixels, 20 pixels here, you see, it pushes pushes
it to the left, because it's the right property.
So we want to say negative here, okay, negative 25
pixels or something. Okay, maybe 35. No, 30 Okay,
so that looks pretty good. Alright, so now we
are done with the scoreboard. Now we want to get
this thing working. Okay. So right now it's super
small and block. So we'll change that. And we call
it a dot result. Yes. So we'll say dot result.
And let's enter a bunch. Bring it to the top,
okay. And now we'll say font size, okay.
40 pixels. Let's see how it looks. Okay,
that looks pretty big. Alright, and now we'll do
font color to be white. Fresh. We also want to
text align to the center. So we'll do dot
result. h1, text, align, center. Refresh,
okay. Whoa. Why is it not working? Oh, it's a p
tag. It's not an h1 tag. Silly me. p tag. Okay,
that looks good. And we will also change the font
family to ASAP. I should really put this at the
top instead of repeating font family every single
time because it's going to be the same font, but
it's okay. All right. So now we have that. I think
we also need to make it bold. So we'll do font
weight. Weight of bold. Okay, refresh. Alright,
that looks good, right? Yep. Is the color a little
bit different? I think it's a bit different on
mine than here. Why is that? Let's, I think the
real color is this. Right here. Okay, so now let's
see if that works. Okay, there it is. That looks a
lot better. Okay. Cool. All right. Now let's go
over the actual images. Okay, for the choices,
The Rock, paper, scissors hand, okay, so we'll do
for that we'll go down here. And index dot HTML,
we call the choices and then choice for each one
of them. Okay, so we have to do is we'll say the
first thing we'll do is start choice. Okay, we'll
grab each one. And we'll do display inline block.
Okay, so that will make it horizontal. Cool. And
now we also need to text align this. So we'll do
go to the parent. pecks align, center, refresh.
Okay, that's how it looks like. And we also want
some marginson because we want some space at the
top and bottom. So we'll do margin of whatnot
margin left margin of 50 pixels of top and bottom
and we'll do zero. Okay. So refresh. Alright,
that's how it looks like. I think we also need a
border. So we'll do go to the choice and we'll say
border of four pixels, solid, solid white. Okay,
so it looks, looks okay. That looks pretty good.
And now we also want to make it circular, right?
So for that it's pretty simple border radius and
you Always want it to be the half of the width. So
right now our width, I don't know what the width
is here. But the point is because you don't know
the width every single time you want to do 50%.
Okay, because you don't know the exact width
in pixels. I mean, we can find out, but it's
not that practical. Okay? You always want to use
percentages. Save, refresh. Okay, that looks good.
We also need some padding. So we'll do padding
of 20 pixels. Let's see how it looks. I don't
know. Okay, that's too much. Let's instead do 10
pixels. Okay, that's a lot better. Okay. Now, we
also want some space in between each choice. Okay,
so for that, we'll give it a margin. Okay, margin
of zero pixels to the top and bottom, and we'll
do 15 pixels to the left and right. All right,
that looks good. Maybe 2020 pixels. Okay, it looks
good, right? No change. Okay. I think that's it
for the images. But now we also want something to
be happening when we hover over You see, when we
hover over it, the background changes, right?
And cursor changes from this pointer to like,
this hand tool, right? So what we do is for that,
we go down here, we do dot choice, hover. Okay,
on hover, we want the background to change. And
also we want the cursor to change. So cursor,
we want to say pointer. Okay? So that's how you
change it. Now when I go over it, okay, that's
the working version. Let's go here, refresh. There
it is. Right, it changes. So we have that working.
Now. Let's also change the background. So we'll
do background of what's a color, I don't know what
the color is, let's say. Let's just do something
darker. Let's go here. Get that. And yeah,
let's do this. Okay. All right. That looks good.
Now that works. But if you notice something, when
when I hover over it, the color of the background
changes right away, right? Like, instantly, okay?
So let me give it something else. For now let's do
a read or something. Right, it changes instantly,
we don't want that we want something more smooth.
Okay, so we go here and do transition. And we can
do all 0.3 S is k. So 0.3 s 0.3 seconds for how
many seconds? And S is you know, seconds. So here,
if I do one, as you see, it's pretty slow, right?
But that's not so natural. It's way too slow. So
what you want to do is 0.3 Okay, that's what I use
usually. So now it's a little bit more natural,
right? So let's go back and change this color.
back to that. So we'll do was it this coat? No,
this color. Okay. There it is. Okay, cool. So
now once we're done with that, let's make this
Make your move thing work. So that's called the
action message. So we'll do action message. And
this one's pretty simple, like, text align
this to center. color is white, font family,
repeating for the 100 million time. All right,
that looks good. Um, we also want it to be bold,
and a little bit bigger, font way to be bold,
and font size to be 20 pixels. Okay. All right,
that looks good. Mmm, hmm. Why is that going
down? Oh, okay, if you notice something here
are making movies a little, you know, shifted
downwards, a little bit more than the original
one. So for that that's happening because we have
50 pixels for the choices, you see that choices,
this this whole thing, this whole thing, right.
And this one has a margin, top of 50 and bottom
of 50. So to fix this, what we can do is say
just margin top here, instead of doing a margin,
like that. So now it would only give us the margin
top, and now that's too close. But now we can add
a margin top here. of 20 pixels or something.
All right, there it is. Whoops, we're missing a
period. So let's get that. Alright, so that looks
good. Alright guys. So that's it for Rock Paper,
scissors, HTML and CSS part. We're going to do the
JavaScript part. Okay, so I'm excited. I'm sure
you're excited. So what are we waiting for? Let's
get into it. Let's get into it. So I have my atom
open in there. Right hand side and the app open
and left hand side. This is the working version.
So let's first take a look at how the JavaScript
is working. Okay, so I'm going to refresh here.
And when I click on the rock, boom, rock user
loses to paper, okay? Boom. I haven't fixed all
of it yet, but we'll fix it. Okay. It's supposed
to be subscripted, all of it. So when you click
on rock, if you when it goes, Hey, you know, you
won, and the user score goes up. And when you win
the border, there's a green border, it stays there
for like, 300 milliseconds, and then it goes away.
Okay? If it's a draw, then it's the gray color.
So that's a draw. Okay? And you probably notice
the numbers didn't change, okay? And if it's,
if you lost, then it'll give you a red border.
border. border. border. So, okay, you won. Come
on. I can't lose. I just can't lose. What? Okay,
cool. There you go. Okay. So that's, that's what
happens when you lose, it's, again, all the other
values work as well as the other buttons. Okay,
so let's go over to index HTML. And before I write
any JavaScript, let's make sure that we add our
JavaScript or link our JavaScript to HTML, okay.
And again, we do that right before the ending
body tag, yo. Okay. AB dot j, s. Okay, we have
that. And once we have this, we can just go to
here and just do Hello. Let's see what that gives
us. Refresh. Okay, let's first open this file.
Okay, because this is the working version. This
is the final version. So we'll go to here open in
browser. Okay. So this is what we have right now.
Right now, nothing worked. You see, when I click
on it, nothing works, because we haven't done
any of that yet. So let's go to console and let's
make sure that our JavaScript is working, and it
is working. Cool. So now let's go to App dot j. s,
let's collapse that thing. All right. Okay, so the
first thing that I'm going to do is cache the DOM.
Okay, so then you're like Tenzin, what the hell
is cache the DOM? What? What does it mean? Okay,
let me first do it. And then I'll, I'll explain,
okay, so so the first thing we need are the
actual scores, right? So the actual variable,
so then what we can do is, say const, I'll call
them user score equals zero, okay, it start,
it's going to start at zero cons to computer score
equals zero, okay, now, we're going to update this
later, depending on who wins and stuff like that.
But we also need to show it to the page, right,
the document that our DOM. So for that, what we'll
do is, say, const. Users score lm, or just say,
underscore span, equals document dot get element
by ID user score, because we gave it and gave it
an ID of user score right here. If you remember
right there, right. And then we're going to do
the same thing for computer score. Okay, so let's
copy that paste. And I'm just going to do computer
score here. underscore span tag, and this is going
to be computer score. Let's go to computer. Okay,
cool. So now you're wondering why the hell am I
doing this type this weird thing right here. Okay.
So, I, this is my own style, okay? You want to be
consistent, okay. You don't necessarily have to do
this. So now underscore, I put it there to clearly
differentiate between normal variables. And then
Dom variables. Okay, so these are Dom variables,
right? So like HTML variables that store DOM
elements, okay. So I can clearly tell that and
also now when I put span because I put those
things in a span tag. Now I can clearly tell that,
hey, it's in a span tag. Okay. So that's just my
way of doing things. Okay. You can do your own
ID, you don't have to put the underscore there.
You can just do span tag here. Right. But that's
just what I do. Okay. So I think it's a pretty
good idea to do do it this way. Because you can
tell, okay, it's a it's a very dumb variable just
because of the underscore and then you know, what
type of element It is like by span tag, div tag,
input tag, right? Whatever it is, you just put
that and then later on when you're debugging and
trying to look through your HTML files can be so
much easier. Okay. So I highly, highly recommend
you do this. Okay. All right. Now, let's get
the scoreboard I'm going to call it scoreboard
underscore div because I stored that in a div
tag, okay. It's a div. tag and then do document
dot query selector or, yeah, query selector
and I'm going to say dot scoreboard. Okay? And
that's because we call it scoreboard right here.
Okay, we gave it a class of scoreboard. Alright,
so once we have this, let's keep going. Let's
get this result div. So I'll go here and say
result div, div, okay? Equals document dot query
selector, dot result. And now let's also get the
rock paper scissor buttons. Okay, so for those,
we're just going to do const rock div, because I
stored that in a div I think. Yep. Yep. And I'm
gonna do document dot get element by ID equals,
that's going to be our okay. Yep. And copy
paste. And this is going to be paper, div,
and P, this is going to be PS. And let's go here
and do rock paper, scissors. If, okay. Alright,
so now we have cached the DOM. Now let's go
back to why we call it caching the DOM. Okay,
so so caching the DOM really means. So caching in
general really means storing something for future
use. Okay. So here, what we're doing is we're
doing exactly the same thing, we're storing all
of these things in variables so that we can use
it later. Okay. And it's not just for convenience
sake, right? It's user score span, it's a lot like
smaller, like less to write, then document dot get
element by ID user score every single time, right.
But there's also a performance factor. So imagine,
every time we need to do something, we need to
use that document, get element by ID user score,
we need to get that reference point. Imagine us
doing document dot get element by ID every single
time, right? When we do that, what we're doing is
we're doing a running a process, and we're running
that process every single time, we need to get
the reference to that element instead of storing
that in a variable once, and then we use that
variable again, because the variable already has
the reference to that element. Okay? It's like,
imagine you're at a library, right? And you're
working on this research paper. And you need to
get the source for your research paper, right?
You need a lot of sources from this particular
book. And now every time you need that book,
you get away from that you stand up, you get away
from the table, your desk, and then you go to that
shelf, find that book, take it out, read it,
find that source. And you're like, Huh, okay,
you memorize it, and then you put it back, you
go to your desk, and then write the source down.
And then when you need some other sources, again,
you go back to that book, and you repeat the same
process again and again, right? That's terrible,
right? very inefficient, it's going to take you
years, okay, to finish that paper. Instead, what
you can do is go, go find that book, bring it,
place it down temporarily here, so that your
book is right here on your table of your desk,
if you need a source. So then what you can do
is go here, okay, I need a source. All right,
cool. Better yet, just leave the book open.
Right. So that's like caching the DOM right?
Instead of doing document dot get element document
dot query selector, every single time you play it,
that is stored in a variable, so then it's just
running that process one time, and then we have
the reference point in that variable. So we're
really being efficient in terms of performance and
also convenience, right? It's really convenient.
Alright, so let's, let's move forward. Alright, so
now let's talk about what happens when we click on
those individual buttons. Okay, so when we click
on rock, what we need to do is take that value,
okay? It's a rock and then compare it against a
computer's choice, which is just going to be a
random choice between those three options. And
then we compare those two, and then check who wins
and then display the result back on the DOM in the
DOM. Okay, so I'm going to first add some event
listeners to each button. Okay, so we'll do add,
add rock div dot add event listener, on a click.
I want to write a function. And that function is
just going to do console dot log. Hey, you clicked
on rock. Okay, so let's see if this works. Okay,
so refresh, and inspect. Go to console. And now
I'm going to click on rock. Okay, there it is,
right. Once you click on it, it goes hey, you
clicked on rock right? Now, let's do the same
thing for these three. Okay, so we'll do three
DD Well, not DD. Let's do okay, that's fine.
All right, so now we'll change this to paper div.
We'll change that to paper. And we'll change this
to scissors. And Come on, and we'll change this to
scissors diff as well. Okay, so now refresh. And
now when I click on rock, it's gonna say, hey, you
clicked on rock. When I click on paper, it's gonna
say, hey, you clicked on paper. And same thing
for the scissors, right? There it is. There we go.
Okay, so now that we have those buttons working,
let's go further. Okay, so right now we're just
console dot logging, we don't want to console dot
log, okay, we want some things happening. Okay,
other than console dot log. So what I'll do is I
will create a function called game, okay, so I'm
going to pretend like I've already created that
sum game. And then if the user clicks rock diff,
I'm going to provide an argument of rock, okay? R.
And if the user clicks paper, I'm going to give it
an argument of P. And then if the user clicks
scissors, I'm going to give it a give it an
argument of S. Alright, so let's get rid of the
console dot log console dot log. And if I refresh,
right, now, nothing's gonna happen, it's gonna
give an error because it says, game is not
defined, okay? Because we don't have a function
defined for a game. So let's do that. Before I
do that, I'm actually going also going to create
a function called main, and then wrap all of this
inside of that. Okay, let's do this. And come down
here, and then we will indent all of this stuff.
Okay, cool. And now to run this, we'll just do
main up top here. Okay, so now if I refresh,
right, it's still going to give you that error,
because game is not defined. So then we can define
that game down here. We'll actually just keep it
you know, in a chronological order. So now let's
define a function called game. And, of course,
our game function is going to take a user input,
right? user choice in this case. So what we're
saying is, again, when somebody clicks on any of
these buttons, take the value of those buttons,
whatever it is RPS, right Rock, paper, scissors,
and then compare it against a computer choice,
and then get the result back. Okay, so here,
we're just gonna say user choice, choice, user
choice, choice, choice, choice, user choice, and
let's say console dot log. Poop for now, okay, so
let's copy that and paste that a couple of times.
And we'll do plus, and we'll do user choice, okay,
whatever it is. So choice, what is happening? Come
on, give me I don't know why it's not doing that.
But let's do that. Alright. So now let's see what
happens. Okay. So now, what I will do is click on
these buttons, and it should basically give me you
know, whatever I pressed on it. RPS, this gives
me r p. s, it's kind of hiding in there, but it's
there. I promise you right there. Okay. So let's
go back. Rock, paper, scissors, right. So again,
it's just a function that we're calling here,
right? So when we call this r gets passed in here,
and then this gets passed to this, and you know
how functions work, okay, if you don't know how
functions work, go watch my go take my JavaScript
course. Okay? So, go do that. Alright, so once
we have this, again, we don't want to console dot
log. So we know that we have our user choice. But
now we need a computer choice. Okay, so to get
a random computer choice, I'll just put that in
a separate function. Okay. So I want you guys to
be comfortable with at running functions in other
functions, okay. So what we'll do is function and
we'll say get computer choice. Okay, and we'll
just do this. Alright. So what are what are the
options, right? What are the choices? The choices
are our P as K. So we'll create the choices const
choices equals an array, and we'll say well,
are P and S? Okay, so we have those. And now to
get a random element from the choices array. We
do that with the help of the built in object in
JavaScript called math. Okay. I think we've used
that in the Unit Converter. Yeah, I think so. So
we can do things like Matt. So here, let's just
do console dot log math dot random Okay, so that's
where you use math dot random. Math is a built in
object in JavaScript. And random is a method that
exists in that math object. Okay, so we can use
that. So what this does is it gives you a random
number between zero and one. Okay? So you're like,
What? What does that help with anything? Let's go
into that in just a little bit. But let's first
see what this does. Okay, so we'll do refresh. And
we have that refresh, refresh, refresh, refresh,
refresh, right? It'll never go. It'll never reach
one always be between zero and one. Okay? It will
be a random number. Basically, now what we
can do is say, okay, it's a number between
zero and one is cool. But in this case, we don't
want that. Okay, what we want is a random number
between zero and three, right? 01 or two. So
then we can say, Okay, if it's if we get one,
we can just do Oh, choices. One, give me P. If
we get a random number, let's say zero, we can
just do choices zero, which is our right. So how
we do that is with times three, okay? You're like,
how does that work? How does that work? Well,
let's, let's see. Okay, so refresh, refresh,
it'll never go over three. You see, will always
be like 01 or two, you see that? I'm refreshing
like a maniac right now. And how that works
is let's do some math here, like zero point,
let's do something really low, right? between zero
and one, which is like 0.01 or something. So let's
do 0.0001 times three, well, that's just going
to give you something really close to zero. Okay,
that makes sense. And now let's do something
really close to one. Okay, so let's do 0.99999
times three, you see, it never reaches three.
So that's how we get random numbers between zero
and three. If you want random numbers between zero
and 10, all we do is just put 10 there. That's
it. And now you get random numbers between zero
and 10. Okay, you will never reach 10. Okay, if
you want it to reach 10, you can just do 11 there.
Okay. But again, this is not helpful to us. Again,
let me change that back to three. This is still
not helpful because we still can't do choices,
you know, 0.4, right? It doesn't make sense. Okay.
So what we need to do is actually rounded down,
okay, make it a poll number instead of a decimal
number. Okay, so for that, we use another method
that exists in the math object called math dot
floor. Okay. And that's it. So now, refresh,
look at that. 1120 I'm refreshing like maniac
again, command R, you see, it will always be
a random number between zero and three, right?
01 or two. So now what we can do is instead of
console logging this, we can just store that in a
variable. So we'll do a random number equals that.
Okay, cool. So we have that so far, but now we
don't want the number we want the element. So we
can just do return choices. Random number. Okay,
so now let's run this. refresh, refresh. Whoa.
What is going on here? Let's see. It doesn't seem
to be working. Uh, oh, we didn't console dot log,
this console dot log. Go here. Okay. There it
is. Right. refresh, refresh, refresh, refresh,
refresh, refresh, refresh, refresh, refresh. So
it's going to be a random, it's going to basically
give you a random element from that choices array.
Okay. So let's get rid of that. We know that our
function works. So now we can move forward in
that game, user choice function. Okay. So now we
have user choice. Now we need to get the computer
choice. So we can just do const. Computer choice.
Choice equals get computer choice. And that's it.
Okay, so now, let's do console dot log computer
choice here. But we know it works. But let's just
test it for the hell of it. Let's go down here a
game. And let's just do C or something. It doesn't
really matter right now. So you see that? Right?
It basically gives you the random computer choice.
So again, if I do console dot log, user choice,
let's do user choice. I don't know let's do
something like user choice. That plus, yeah,
let's do that. And then let's go here. Get that
guy. Put it down here. And we'll do this is going
to be computer choice. Maybe I'm going overboard
here, but let's, let's test it. Okay. There it
is. Okay. So again, refresh. You see the computer
choice always changes, but the user choice doesn't
change because we said See, right? So, but if we
get rid of that, and actually press on a button
Now, let's see what happens. Right? So now when I
click on the our rock, it's always going, the user
choice is always going to be wrong, are and the
computer choice changes, right? It's going to be
random. And if I click on the hand, right Rock
paper, then it's going to be the user choice is
always going to be P, and then the computer choice
changes again. And then if I click on scissors,
it's going to be as the user choice is going to be
asked and computer is going to change again. Okay?
All right. So once we have this now, what we can
say is, now we have to compare, right? Now we do,
if you know, user picks, rock and computer pick
scissor, then it's a win, right? If the user picks
paper and the computer picks scissor, then it's a
loss, right? So we have to do that. So then, now
what we can do is, instead of using if statements,
I'm going to use switch statement here,
I'm going to give you a quick intro here, but I
highly recommend you check out the documentation,
we can check the documentation of switch. So
basically, how it works is, let's say we have
a variable here called name, okay, and we'll just
say name is David. Alright. And now, usually what
we do is if name equals, you know, David, you
know, console dot log. Hello, right? If we do
and then else, if name is equal to pineapple,
then then then do console dot log, hey, right.
And then, depending on how the name changes,
it's going to either do Hello, or Hey, right,
if I put right now it's going to do Hello, because
name is David. Right? But if I put pine there,
console dot log Hello is going to run, okay, but
switch statements, how it works is very similar.
All you do is switch. And then the argument. So in
this case, it's named right. And then what you do
is case and say if the case is Apple, colon, all
I want you to do is say hello, console dot log,
or console dot log, this is Apple, and then break.
And then all you do is say, case, pine, then
I want you to do console dot log something else,
like whatever. And then well, and then break here,
right? So this is how switch statements work.
Okay, very similar. You can do everything that
you can do it's do with switch statements with
if statements and vice versa. But in some cases,
switch statements make things a lot easier than
if statements. So here, what we can do is say,
switch. User choice, plus computer choice. Okay.
So let's first take care of all the cases, all
the situations when the user wins. Okay, so the
user will win. If the user choice is R, and rock,
and the computer choice is paper. Yep. And if the
user choices, paper, and the computer choice is
rock, and if the computer choice, user choice is
scissors, and the computer choice is rock, no,
paper, yeah. Yeah, rppr s p, okay. In those cases,
what we want to do is say console dot log, user
wins, okay? And then break, you always need to
put that break, or else it'll keep going to the
bottom. We don't want that. So we'll also do case.
So now we'll take care of when the user loses. So
if the user picks rock and the computer picks,
what happens with puck, paper, okay. And user
picks, Rock paper and computer picks scissors,
and rock, scissors, and computer picks rock,
okay, in those cases, we just want to say console
dot log. Computer wins. Okay, or user loses. Let's
just keep things very consistent loses All right,
and break again. Okay, now let's do the same thing
for the rest. So we'll do five why why paste?
Okay, cool. And now for the case that last one
is if the if they're both equal, right, so we can
just do RR this one simple, right? Rp Rs. Okay,
cool. So are our PP SS in those cases it just it's
draw. Okay. All right. So that's it. So now, let's
see what happens when we click on these buttons.
All right, so I'm going to refresh here. Nothing's
there. Click on rock one time. Well, nothing
happened. Okay, let's hold on. Let's do it again.
Click on rock. Okay, cool. I don't know what
what happened there. Click on rock, okay. It's,
it works. User wins. User wins. I'm click keep
clicking. It's a draw. It's a wins wins. I'm never
losing. I think there's something's wrong there.
Is something wrong there? I think something's
wrong there. Let's see. Oh my god, silly me. Okay,
so here it's not supposed to be. Rp. It's supposed
to be rock and scissors. Right? If computer as
user picks rock and computer picks, scissor user
still wins. Okay, so I knew something was wrong
there. But I was just so gone earlier. Okay,
so let's refresh and see if it works. Okay, so
now we have loses some losers, some wins and some
drop, okay? Which is, which makes sense. So if I
click on the hand icon, paper, we have some wins
some losers and some drops. Same thing for the
scissors. Okay, so we know that our game function
works, okay. But now, it's just another console
dot log, right? It's not showing anything up
there on the page. It's not doing anything, right,
which is not what we want. Alright. So for this,
what we can do is we can, again, separately create
different functions for winning, losing and draw,
okay, we never want to put an jam all the logic
in one function never, ever, okay? Because then
later on, it's it's hard to read. It's hard to
debug, it's hard to work with other people. It's
just bad. Okay. So instead of logging winds and
stuff like that, what we'll do is we'll say winds
create a function called wins. Okay, so right
now we're just pretending that we've already
created a function called wins. Okay? So when the
user wins, actually, let's do win, okay. And when
the user wins, I want to do something with the
win function, okay? And I also want to do when
the user loses, I want to do lose, and then when
the user draws, it's when it's draw, just wanted
to drop. Okay, now, I can go up top here and do
those functions again. So let's do function. When,
and then let's just console dot log when for now.
Okay? I just want to, again, test it right away.
Okay, don't move forward. I mean, this is like,
we know this is gonna work, but I'm just trying
to prove a point. Okay. So let's do y, paste,
paste. Okay, let's go here. Alright, cool. So now,
if for this one, lose, come on, lose. And this
is going to be lost, and go down here. This is
going to be draw, and we'll just say draw. Okay.
Alright. So now, let's see what happens. Okay, so
it's still working. So, again, let's go back and
start working. Okay. So right now we have when,
and now when we when we want to show? What do we
want to do? First, we want to first increase the
user score, right? So the first thing we do is
we go up, we have user score and computer score,
right? So what we can do is, say user score. User
score plus plus. That's it. All right. And let's
go to the last I mean, it's, it's this is not
really, really realistic. Usually, you don't
like work in three functions functions at once,
right? But I'm just showing you here, you can
just do like, computer score plus plus here, okay?
But we're not going to do that. We're just work on
this function, and then work on this and then work
on draw, okay, so, one at a time. Alright. So user
score plus plus, and now let's just show you the
score. Okay, let's see what it is. Okay. And let's
wait for it. Let me hold on. Let's do console dot
log. It's a win. Okay. Alright, so now refresh.
And let's see what happens. Okay. It's a draw.
Let's keep clicking draw, draw, draw, draw. Okay,
so now it's saying assignment to constant. Okay.
So what's happening right now, it's saying you're
trying to Change the constant variable, okay, this
const. So what we do is instead of const, we can
either use let, or var, okay? We should we should
be okay using lead here, okay, so we can just use
let. Alright, so now let's go back here and do
the same thing. Draw you see that when you when
you when we when the score went up by one, and
it's a one now again, if I keep clicking You see,
whenever we when it goes up Holy crap, we just
won like, seven at once or something like eight,
eight times in a row. That's crazy. So let's go
back. And instead of when here, I don't want when
I don't want to console dot log user score, what I
want is, I want to show it on the page. So what we
do is instead of console dot logging, we just go
user score span, okay? Because that's the element,
right? Because we're saying usually get element by
ID user score, and that's the span tag, this span
tag right here. Okay, so let's go back. And all
we do is use your score span dot inner HTML equals
user score. That's it. Alright, so now, and then
we can also do the computer score, right? So we'll
also update the computer score, even though right
now since we only have the wind function, it's not
going to the computer score is going to remain
the same. So let's do equals computer score.
Okay. All right. So now, let's keep clicking, you
see that? When the user wins, the score goes up,
right? Again, it says assignment to constant
variable. Oh, innerHTML. Alright, not in our text,
HTML. Okay. Refresh. And that should be okay.
Now. Okay. So every time we when the user score
goes up, okay, so once we have the score, and now
we need to actually display the message that says
paper, beats rock or whatever, right? And for
that, we can't do that yet. Okay. And that's
because we, we don't have anything that says,
you know, any reference in our wind function,
right? We have that in our game function, but not
in our wind function. Okay? So what we can do is
give it some parameters here and say, user choice,
and computer choice, okay? Or you can just say
user computer doesn't really matter what you call
it, okay? A, B, you can call it anything you want,
okay? I'm just gonna call it user choice. Computer
choice, okay. And down here, again, just to just
so you guys don't get confused. I'll just do
user computer for now. Okay. And then down here,
what we can say is when when you actually run
the function, right? This is defining a function,
but when you actually run the function, pass in,
whatever the whatever the user choice and computer
choices, okay? So as the as an argument here, I'll
just do user choice, and then computer choice,
okay. And then I do that for all of the other
ones. So user choice, and computer choice,
and we'll define the lose and draw function in a
bit. So user choice, and computer choice. Okay.
And now let's do console dot log user. Choice, not
user choice, let's just do user because remember,
we changed it so that you guys don't get
confused computer, and refresh. And now you see,
it's going to be RS every single time because
it's always going to be a win, right? Because
this is a win function, it only takes care of
win, right? It's not going to take care of when
you lose and draw. Okay? So that's what happens.
But we don't want that what we want is, we don't
want to console dot log, we want to show it on
the page. So what we do is get the result div,
result div dot inner HTML and say, you know, user
choice. Plus beats plus computer choice. Okay,
and then we'll say plus, you win. Okay, so let's
see if this works. So let's wait for one way when
user choice is not defined, why is it that
okay, we call the user and computer I can I
keep forgetting that? So we'll just call it user
choice. Okay, that just makes more sense. So we'll
do user choice computer choice. Okay. All right.
I don't know why it's doing that right now. Oh,
okay. So when we actually got the reference to
that element, we said, document dot query selector
dot result, okay. And if we take a look at our
index dot HTML, we stored that not The result I
mean, we did but it's inside of a p tag inside of
the result. Okay? So here really what we want is
say, P, okay? Get the p tag, get the paragraph
tag inside the result. So now when we actually
change this, it's going to be a paragraph. Okay,
so here we should really call this not div, but P.
Alright, so let's go down here. And where's the?
Where do we use resolve p anywhere else? Let's
hope not. Okay. And let's go here, and let's call
it P, and this should work. And now let's see,
when we when there is Orbitz as you will,
right. However, Orbitz S is not so readable,
okay? Our beats s not so readable. We want it
to be human readable, okay. So what we can do is
convert this to rock and this to scissors, okay,
and we'll create another functions for those,
okay, for those things. So in this case, a
function, not functions, okay? function and
we'll call it convert to word or something.
Alright, and it'll take in a letter, and then
we just do if the letter is equal to r, just
return rock. If the letter is equal to P paper,
return paper. And if those two are not met,
then just return scissors. Okay. Okay, so now,
here, what we can do is just say convert to word.
And go down here as well convert to word. Okay,
and refresh. You see that? Right now? It says
paper covers rock, because we're not winning.
It's a draw, draw. But then when you win rock
beats scissors, okay, you win. Okay, so that
works. But now, while we're at it, I also want
to introduce you guys to some ies six. Okay, so,
right now, this is the CS five right here, right?
When you have to combine a variable with a string,
all you do is plus, okay, which is cool, but not
so cool. Okay. So in year six, there's something
called template strings. And all you do is with
the backticks. Okay, and if you don't know what,
where the backtick is, you can Google that.
But on a Mac, it's on the top, left corner,
right below the escape button, okay, and Windows
is probably there. But if it's not just look it
up on your keyboard, you should be able to find
it. Okay? And then all you do is wrap the end in
a backtick as well. And that's it. Okay, so now
you can get rid of the pluses and, and the quote,
so let's do that, get rid of that. Get rid of
that. And let's get rid of the pluses there,
you win. Okay, that's good. Let's get rid of the
quotes at the end there. And now, the Convert to
word user choice is not a string, right? Right.
Now, if I displayed this is just going to display
them as strings, which is not cool, right? That's
what right? That's not cool. So what we do is,
if it's a variable, in this case, it's
going to, you know, return it's a function,
so we just do dollar sign and wrap that with curly
brace. Okay. So that's all it is. Okay. And then
we do the same thing with convert. And there you
go. Alright, paper covers rock, you will keep
going rock beats scissors, right? Now, there's,
it's not going to say convert to word user choice,
you see? Right? So this is a lot more readable.
Okay, so now that we have the basic functionality
of the wind function working, now that we have
that we can move on and just copy this, okay,
copy this and just paste it right here. Okay,
so we can just say, actually, before that,
let's work on one more thing before we move on.
Okay. So right now we have rock beats scissors,
but it's still like not clear who's winning
who, right? You can see your numbers going
up. But you can't really tell who's who's who
picked rock and who picked scissors. Okay,
you can kind of you know, calculate that because
if you pick rock, of course, you're the one who
picked rock. But let's keep let's make that super
clear. So what we can do is right here, we can
just add something and we'll just say we can just
Somebody do something like, you know, let's do,
let's just do, this is always gonna be user, right
user and this is always going to be computer comp.
Okay? This is cool. Like, that's cool, but
it's a little too long. Okay, I don't want to,
I don't want to make that and it's, it just
doesn't look good. Okay, I thought about doing it,
you know, make, like putting a picture somewhere
here, right? That'd be pretty cool. But I didn't
I wanted to keep it keep things simple. Okay. So
here, what we can do is say const. do small word
or small user word. Yeah. Small. user. Word. Sure.
Or equals user, and just do dot font size. Okay,
that's how you control the font size. Okay. And
also, I also did this so that I can expose you
to these little, you know, string methods in
JavaScript. Okay. So user dot font size, we'll
do three, okay, we'll make it super small. And
then we'll superscript that. Okay, so now, what
we can do is make the same thing and do comp. And
then we'll do font size of three and superscript.
That as well. So superscript is basically let me
let me remove that for now. And let's first Well,
let's first let's go up, up, okay, so now instead
of user here, we just put that in a curly brace,
okay, like that. And then do small user word. And
then we'll say, come down here and do the same
thing with this guy. So we'll do small comp word.
Wait, I don't think I call it comp word. Okay,
let's go up. Yep. For this one. It's gonna be
small comp word. Okay. And this is going to be
calm font size three. So let's see how it looks
now. Come on, you see that? So that's how it looks
right now. But right now it's on the same line.
So what I want to do is, I don't know superscript
or subscript, I think subscript word would work
better. So subscript superscript, would do this.
Let's do that as up, dot s up, okay. And these
methods exists on the string object in JavaScript,
it's built into JavaScript. So and if you put s
up, it's gonna move that down, or be the fresh,
there. Let's okay. So this looks a lot nicer than
just that. Okay? Again, if you guys prefer the
brackets, it's okay. Doesn't the parentheses It's
okay, you get you guys can use it. Okay, bracket,
parentheses, you parentheses. See, please use that
if that's easier to understand. Okay, so alright,
so we have the basic functionality working. So
what I want to do is, I just want to copy all of
this, okay? So I'll just do copy and paste. Okay?
Because the functionality is going to be the same
thing, right? And let's do this and let's paste
that as well. Okay, so we have that. And let's
indent that. way. What? Okay, so we indented that.
Alright, so now let's take care of loops. And then
we'll go into draw, okay? So right now, when we
lose, we don't want the user score to go up. We
want the computer score to go go up. Right? And
we don't want let's see, we don't want we want
to show this right? You just spend innerHTML
equals dad, that is good. That is good. That is
good. And then in the result p what we want to
say is do loses, too. Okay? loses to computer.
You lost. And not. Not that. Okay, hold on. Okay,
not that. And that's it. So now, when we lose it,
you do that too. Let's let's add in a poop there.
Okay. Okay, let's do that. Refresh. Okay, whoa,
user choice is not defined. What's going on? Let's
see. It says app j. s, line 38. User choices not
Oh, okay. You see that? We didn't define it here.
Okay, user choice. Computer choice. All right. So
refresh. And you when, let's see what happens. You
lost. Okay. We have a poop. That's a happy food.
He's happy even if even we lose. Okay, cool. So we
have that and you can see that the computer score
goes up when we lose You see, whenever we lose the
computer score goes up, okay? And when is draw,
nothing happens right now because we need to,
again code that. Okay. Okay, so we have done
that. And now let's go to the draw. And here we
don't do user score plus plus or do any plus plus,
because let's draw, nobody goes up. Okay? You can,
like make both of them their score go up, but that
just doesn't make sense. So we'll just do those
two. And we don't need to do these right? Yeah,
we don't need to do that. And, or do we? Let's
see. Yeah, we don't need to do any of that. For
a draw. For draw, we can just keep Yeah, we can
just keep that the same. So it just like, equals,
we'll just say equals, and we'll do it's a draw.
Okay, and what emoji should I use? Boring now? I
don't know. Let's just use apple. Let's just not
use anything. Okay. Um, okay. User choice is not
defined. Again, in our draw, we got to define
that. So choice user, computer choice, refresh,
and look at that. So now when we when is
going to say when C. And when we lose,
it's gonna say last, right? And when we do,
draw, it's a rock equals rock. And it's a
draw. Okay. All right. So that's pretty much it
in terms of the main logic of our app. Alright,
now let's add some finishing touches and do the
little things. Okay, you know what they say? They
say the difference between the good and the great.
Is that little extra, okay, that little extra? I
don't know who said it, but the first time I heard
it, I mean, and that's why I still suck. Okay,
let's keep going. So if you notice on the
working app, refresh, I don't know why that
piece that but doesn't matter. So when I click
on it, you see if it's a draw, it's that gray,
it adds that gray border, animated and goes away,
right? If I lose, that happens, and if I win,
let's see if I win. There we go. Right, the green
thing, good border appears. So for that, what we
can do is in our win, lose and draw functions, we
can add some things to it. Okay, so what we do is
we can first work with the win, okay, so we'll
do is go here. And let's go to our working app,
right now, if I refresh, nothing happens, right? I
mean, the message pops up, everything else works,
but animations not there. Okay. So for that, what
we can do is add a class to each of them. Okay,
so when the user wins, and if we click this guy,
it should add a class with some styles to this
div. Okay, so how we do that is, first, we have
to make some styles. I mean, some classes right in
our style, style dot CSS. And this is JavaScript
video, but I left this off for JavaScript,
because I felt like this had more to do with
JavaScript than CSS, okay. So here we can do
green glow. Okay. So when the user wins, we want
some green border to appear. So I'll do border,
four pixels solid, and let's do four D, cc, seven
D, okay. And then we'll get a box shadow, okay,
box shadow of 004 pixels or 10 pixels. And we'll
give it a color, a darker green color. Let's do
three, one, B Four, Three a for this. Okay,
and now let's do the same for red glow. Okay,
red glow, and we do something similar. So, grab
that and in this case, we want to add a color of
something reddish. Let's do FC 121 B. And for
the box shadow color, let's do d 01115. Okay,
and now let's repeat the same process for for
the gray color. So we'll do gray glow, and we'll
do something grayish. 464647. And for this one,
we'll do two five to nine to be more darker. Okay,
that looks good. And if you don't know how the
box shadow works, this is the horizontal vertical
offset. And then you have the blur and the color.
Okay, that's all it is. And then you can, you can
have an optional value here for spread, how far
your shadow should go. But again, you can look
that up. It's super simple. It's not that hard.
So now let's go to the JavaScript part. And here
now that we have those classes, what we can do is
say, when the user wins, okay, when the user wins,
what we want to do is add a class of green glow
to whichever div the user clicked on. Okay, if the
user clicked on the rock div, it should give it
should give that rock div a class of green glow,
okay? And that's going to give that border of
green. Okay, so now for that what we can do is say
document dot get element by ID of our right. But R
is a hard coded letter, right argument. And that's
not what we want, because then it will only give
that green color. Only if we click on the rock,
what what if we want, when we click to on
the paper, right, it's not going to do that,
we'll have to hard code everything. So that's
not what we want to do here, what we want to
do is get the user choice. Okay. And again, user
choice here is whatever your user clicks on it,
and then it's either, you know, it basically
is either r, p or s, okay? It's one letter,
depending on what the user clicked on. Okay. So
we do document dot get element by ID, user choice
dot class list class, this is a method that exists
in the DOM. And with JavaScript, when you do that,
what it gives you is an array of all the classes
on that specific element, okay? And now what we do
is on that array, we just do a dot add, and then
add our class. So then we can just say, dot green
glow here. Okay. And that's it. So now let's see
what happens when we click something. And if we
win, let's see what happens. Okay? refresh, click,
click, click, let's see fly when it's winning,
but it's not doing that. Let's see what why that
is. Oh, I'm not supposed to put the period there.
Because we know it's gonna be a class. Okay? So we
don't need to put that there. Okay. And there it
is. So the border here is not working. Okay. So
the glow is working, the box shadow is working,
but the border is not working. Okay, so it's still
white. And I think there's some CSS conflicts.
So I'm not going to look through everything and
try to fix it. What I will do is I will just put
that important flag, okay, maybe we can just move
all this down at the very bottom, and that should
fix it. Let's try that first. Because putting
the important flag is never a good idea. Okay,
so we'll go down all the way down and put it here.
Okay. Let's see if that makes a difference. Okay.
Let's go here, refresh. And there it is. Okay, so
we didn't have to put that important flag. Okay,
cool. Let's also make sure it works on paper and
scissors, okay, it works on all of them. If we
when clicking on any of those buttons, it will
add a border of green However, it's still green,
right? It's not supposed to be green, if you
go here, right? If we when it just goes back to
white, right? It's, it has that little animation.
So how do we do that? Right? So we do that by
using something called a set timeout function in
JavaScript, okay. And we can do this thing with
CSS. But I just wanted to do this with JavaScript.
So I can introduce you guys to set timeout. Maybe
we've done that with the digital clock. I
think we use set interval there. But yeah,
let's do set timeout. Okay, so let's go over
what set timeout does. So here, let me just
run it in the out in the global scope. Let's do
set timeout, and set timeout takes two arguments,
okay. It's going to take in a function, and let's
do function. And let's just say console dot log.
Hello. Okay. And the second argument it takes is
the time in milliseconds of how long you should
wait before you perform that first argument, first
function. Okay? So if I do 3000 milliseconds here,
which is three seconds, it will wait if I
run this, okay. It will wait three seconds,
and then it will say hello. Okay, so if I refresh
here, let's count 012. Boom, there it is, right.
If I do one second, it should happen in a second.
Refresh, one. There. That's right. So that's how
that works. So let's comment that out. Let's
comment that let's get rid of it. It's pretty
silly. Maybe let's undo and actually grab it. So
then we can just use that in our function there.
And there we go. Okay, so instead of console
dot logging here, what we need to do is run
something else. Okay? And what we do here is, so
we added a class called green glow, right when
we clicked on that div, when we won, but now
right after that, what we need to say is, hey,
wait for three seconds or one second, or however
many seconds and then remove that class. Okay,
so let's do that. So then we can just do document
dot get element by ID of user choice again,
and then dot class list. dot remove. green glow.
Okay, and now, you can see it happening if I go
to let's refresh and let's go to here, inspect.
And let me drag this to the right a little bit.
And let's go look at all these depths. Okay, let's
see what happens when I when Okay, let me refresh
again. I shouldn't have done that. Okay, there
it is. Alright, so I'm going to click on this.
I lost draw. No, there it is. Right. So it was
there for a second and then it went away. Okay,
again. Again, let's come on, let me win. There
you go. Right. It adds that green glow class and
then it removes that, okay, again, again, it works
on the paper and scissors to like, come on, when
they go. scissor goes away. Okay. So right now,
it's not so natural. Because if you notice here,
come on, let me win ones, please. No, no, no, no,
no, no, no. What? Okay, you see, it's, it takes a
little too long for it to go away. So what we
should do is make that like 300 milliseconds,
okay, which I think is a little bit more natural.
So now, if I went here, I don't have luck with
paperless to go with rock. There you go. Right.
It's a little bit more natural. It's faster.
Okay. So now we can just copy and paste this. And
also you can, you can probably, you know, put this
in a variable because we're using it twice here,
right? Let's be efficient. Let's just do it. Okay,
let's just do it. So we'll just go up top here.
And since these are variables, we should probably
move this top here. Okay. And let's just do const.
We'll just call it user choice diff. Let's go
here. And we'll call it document dot get element
by ID. User choice. Okay. And now we can replace
this whole thing with user choice, diff. Okay. And
let's do the same thing with this guy here. User
choice, diff cap, that looks good. And now we can
just copy this two more times. Let's go here. Copy
that. And here instead of green glow, what we want
is red glow, right? Because we lost. And let's go
here as well. red glow. And let's go down. And
for that we can just do, paste. Well. Let's get
that. Okay. And here. Let's just do gray glow.
Let's go up top. Gray below. We'll have to get
that variable as well. So copy, just get to the
top, paste. Paste. And let's move this to the top
as well. All right, so that looks good. Let's
refresh her. Let's see one. Gray. Last. Okay,
this seems to be working. Let's go to the paper.
Gray. Gray. loss. One last. Last gray. Come on.
did I win? Can I can I please when I swear. Okay,
there we go. It's working. Gray last Okay, so last
and gray works. Okay, winning works too. Okay.
All right. So that works. Now I want to do one
last thing before I call it a day. Okay, so let's
go here to our function and let's sexify it. Okay,
so let's, instead of doing it the s5 version
here instead in this inner function in ESX,
what you do is get rid of this function name,
and then add an arrow. Okay? And then if it's
just Just a one liner here, this user's choice div
class list is just one line, right? So for that,
we can just get rid of this curly brace. Okay.
And now let's get rid of it. And this should
still be working. So let's go to red glow,
and see if it works. Let's see, when we lose,
what happens. Come on, can I lose now? There it
is, right? It still works. So we can do the same
thing for all of this. So let's get rid of that.
Add an arrow. And since it's one line, we can just
get rid of this and get rid of that. Cool. And
now let's go to the wind section. And let's do
the same thing. Get rid of these two. Let's go and
get rid of that. And at the arrow, okay, refresh.
It's still working. Whoa, what happened? Oh, get
rid of that. Okay. There it is. It still works.
Cool. Everything looks good. And I think we have
some Yes, five. Yep, yes, five code here. So we'll
also fix these. Alright, so here again, we can
just do the same thing. Just go here at the arrow,
get rid of this, this, get rid of this, this this.
And that's it. And let's do the same thing here.
Get rid of that add an arrow. Well, and let's pull
these up. Get rid of that. Get rid of these to
get rid of these two. All right. And now again,
let's do the same thing. Okay. Okay, that that.
And that's it right? I think that's it. Okay, so
let's make sure it's working before anything. All
right. This is working. All the clicks are working
and looks good. Let me delete the lines here. Wow,
this is looking very, very sexy. Okay, um, I think
that's it. Alright guys. So that's it for rock
paper scissors. If you have any questions, leave
it in the comment section below. Peace out dude.